[Music]
in Elko County the Board of Health has
now voted against Banning covid and flu
vaccines in that area now some who live
there raise some concerns after Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis requested that the
Florida Supreme Court investigate the
possible side effects of the vaccines
the Elko County Board of Health
commissioner John Carr thinks this
shouldn't have even made it on the
agenda tonight
we don't have the authority to do this
even if we were 100 on board with it
where County Commissioners I think were
rather aggressive group and I'm proud of
what we've accomplished
but if we really wanted to vote in this
I think it'd be a huge overstep
so a general consensus from the board
including cars say an individual's
Health Care decisions should be made on
their own and the county shouldn't be
making that decision for them
morally and ethically I also have a
problem with it because we're supposedly
voted on as a constitutional County back
when covet started and my understanding
is that is basically we believe in human
rights of our citizens and quite
honestly our citizen wants to go get a
shot if they talk to their doctor and
know the pros and cons then they're more
than welcome and should be able to
and I don't believe we should do a
moratorium getting the shot just like we
shouldn't do you have to go get the
shots
so the Nevada Department of Health and
Human Services immunization program
still encourages nebadans to talk to
their doctor about vaccinations